hello and welcome to this video the game
before didn't upload it was a disconnect
by the opponent after a couple of moves
so let's start a new one
morteza Jose Hosseini morteza Orsini
knight c6 Knight b5 for the Frankenstein
Dracula
let's not do that
now white normally takes now I think
that's also Knight to f3 this women who
came
hmm
Jim probably just counselling them
Ruki eight white is living a bit
dangerously there when the e-file isn't
that
No some people are very relaxed about
things like that I would be nervous now
96 or do I have some good discovery down
you
it's looking at the f7 square but still
if I go Bishop to g5 Illya where are you
going with the Queen
I mean 94 you know is SEM as part of
this position he has to cover the square
I think and he doesn't
so 94 94
now probably has to go back here read
now I got 94 as one possibility
ninety-four
eggs
eggs I mean this is clearly better for
black right
some Czech or no tink tink
take TIG
you know I just didn't do that ship
takes up seven s something you have to
check but doesn't work
you
now I see no way to defend us what what
this is supposed to play now
I got 92 but you can you can argue here
that maybe there's something about them
so night c2 he moves that take like know
what just to look here
well it's am still to anything better d5
is an attractive move as well
no but I just spotted
the bishop
so not not too shabby
No do I take the rook or what do I take
rook takes a form
III maybe
you
t3 is slightly annoying mucho
anyway
too much material YUM I thought I just
go to HHM
nor it
you
now King takes Queen f3 check
so if he goes d3 what is the best
solution against this he attacks the
rook and my bishop I don't have a move
of the rock group e5 he can take with
the Queen the simplest is to take him
and just say that being a piss-up is
enough
I still have to work a little bit though
for for the full point because I'm not
fully developed
yeah this is threatening night g6
actually
nice g6 so ever good d6
he's got age for stuff
[Music]
well it is not
not super simple
you
h4 h5 96 stop
still um possible
Queen f6 is a useful temple
and Bishop Bishop e5 next
yeah yeah I am that should be I can take
it
it is useful I think
the night on a 1 was kind of a dead
piece on its trade Queens it is the way
to not get checkmated okay so let's have
a look there was a bit of an odd way of
playing forward I think the keel you
take on e5 or play Knight f3
looks odd on a staff because you're
sitting just Yoyogi you're moving into
the e-file and it looks more than
dangerous so knight c6 he went to F for
giving me yet another temple and now I'm
winning him by d4 and maybe rook takes
the stronger yeah this is possible d3
id3 actually have this one
ticking is ticking the the bishop is
probably simpler okay I took the look
away and now Bishop c1 should be played
I actually overlooked Bishop age 4 I
didn't see that this is a move but this
is a good good enough defense I'm just
okay with just the piece ninety six is a
threat so I cannot play whatever for
example this yeah this actually would
work
yeah because here I haven't ever have
this one but let's say I'm trying to
secure this one that's made
pay attention who ok d6 is covering h3
so the maid is not possible he went here
Queen f6 intending but should be 5 and
now this is the easiest way to do it
after the Queen's are traded there is no
way of swindling me anymore and he
resigned ok guys thanks for watching